Hey, how are we? Are we rolling Jamie? We are rolling. Check.
Can you say a how's your water? And my water is refreshing. It's
delicious.
We like to go a little bit heavy on the minerals here in public radio. Hey,
I'm Jad Abumrad I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab and today you'll talk to him about
football. Yes sir. The second half. And uh,
you knew in the first half we talked about, um, where football came from.
Now we want to look at where it's going,
which seems to be the big conversation these days.
And as we were thinking about that, uh,
we ended up talking with one of our favorite sports writers. Uh,
Chuck Klosterman, I'm a writer and a journalist in Brooklyn.
You may know him from his emphasis column in the New York Times.
He also writes about sports for Grantland.
And he recently wrote an essay about football and it's inherent contradictions
and it,
we called for us this sort of Carlisle versus ivy free flow versus traditional
sort of thing, but in a newer sort of modern way. [inaudible] can I ask you,
so your a, I want you to explain this statement.
This is the thing I found most interesting about your essay. Um,
you say basically that by portraying itself as a super conservative,
traditional manly sport, but essentially operating is the opposite.
Like this really liberal wide open,
anything goes kind of sport football became the most successful enterprise in
American sports history. So you have this,
the sense that it's pretending to be one thing but actually another,
what do you mean? Well,
okay. It's,
it's a unique thing in the sense that if you look in a sport like soccer or
baseball, there is a real uh,
sense from the people who sort of, you know, uh,
the institution of the sport to keep the sport the same,
that they want the sport to sort of almost transcend time.
It'd be the same game now as it always is. Uh, soccer particularly,
they hate any kind of attempt to change the rules in this. Um,
football works in the exact opposite way.
Football is constantly evolving and constantly adopting new ideas and new
technologies and is very willing to alter the game in order to make it,
uh, more free flowing or a more progressive game.
I mean football will add things like coaches can talk to the quarterback,
three radio in their helmet.
You know,
the idea of instant replay was added very early on compared to other sports.
The game itself from an offensive perspective
is constantly being reinvented.
Chuck says,
if you look at all the new formations that keep getting added and all the trick
plays that are tried out every year, it is quite clear that football as a game,
it actually is the most liberal sport in terms of adopting ideas.
But the,
the morality of the game in the center of it,
the thing that really draws people to love it is sort of,
it's almost most reactionary qualities that it's still sort of comes down to
the strongest, toughest when,
and this is why I feel like football has,
is both so build for American if the American way of thinking and also didn't
you so popular too.
It allows you to sort of think about the game in a very liberal,
progressive way in a Carlisle way,
but spiritually or like your heart of it can still be this kind of old
comfortable conservative mindset.
There's old ivy fundamentals of power and might and tradition.
I'm just kind of of the belief that that's really what most people want.
Most people want to think of themselves as progressive but feel conservative and
Chuck's whole argument is is that it is football is a unique ability to be both
at the same time reactionary and simultaneously wildly inventive so that you can
think about it one way and feel about it in another.
That is what makes football the the most popular part of our sporting culture,
which it is now right now by a factor of three.
What he means is that the NFL is three times as popular as the next most popular
sport in America.
And the question we got to just cause it's a question you can't really avoid
right now is is it going to stay that way?
Let's just say we're just a weird era for the sport.
Like this is it certainly in my lifetime, the strangest era,
like some weird things are happening.
One is that injuries after injury,
there seems to be no limit to the amount that we can discuss the problems with
the game. Concussions in football. If you're a coach,
how do you handle all this discussion about neurologist and head injuries going
forward? The idea that so many former NFL players are essentially, you know,
decrepit and a lot of had problems study their brains after they die and they
have the brains of people who should've been 180 years old and had Alzheimer's
or whatever. You know,
there was just a kid from Ohio state who shot himself in a dumpster.
He vanished. He sent a text to his mother saying,
I am sorry if I'm an embarrassment and basically in Texas mom and said,
it was like, I think it's concussions that are making me do this.
These concussions have my head all aft and at the same time it is an American
pastime. There seems to be no limit to the popularity of the sport.
Sunday's game was the most watched event in American television history.
I think it's very plausible that the Superbowl this year will be the most
watched sporting event of all time in America. That is, and this is the,
don't you feel a small cold wind in the air?
Like I feel like the times of death, there's totally,
absolutely will.
This will then there's really never been a serious discussion about should we as
a culture be playing football since, since Roosevelt 1905 yes.
And yet no one seems to be stopping themselves from watching these games.
So it's almost like there are these two silos,
two separate streams in our collective unconscious that exists simultaneously in
are both like shooting skyward. Okay. So we've gotta be honest.
Like when chuck was talking about the,
his whole idea of silos shooting a
cool idea,
but we weren't really sure what that meant exactly.
Hey Renee, it's a pleasure to meet you.
Thank you so much for letting me come down. Cool. There's so much more.
That is until our producer and wheeler met this woman, I'm Monet Bartow.
You could add something like if you want, I'm a neighbor. Tell I'm a Libra.
I enjoy long walks on the beach. I'm just joking.
So Monae is a partner at a media production company.
She lives with her husband and their four kids outside of Atlanta, Georgia.
But I actually went to talk to her about her son Parker because Monet says the
very moment he was born. So what do you thinking when, when Parker's born,
as soon as the doctor saw his third thumb,
like yeah, we're going to the NFL babies.
Yes. And then Parker is the 10,001 ounce. He's the biggest thing.
He walked out the world. I'm still going with third
best way. I hadn't heard that. Alright. Um,
so Parker comes out and he's the biggest thing I've ever seen. You know,
I've prepared for months and I have found the perfect outfit to take him home
from the hospital and, and this joker is too big for it,
so right then I'm like all my guy. Yes, yes.
Like he's a boy and he's going to play in the NFL. He's gonna play in the NFL.
A lot of families pass down quilts.
They pass down family businesses. Our family tradition was football,
it was football. My Dad played football.
The lion's lidding Roysher was Mel far for data's Malvar.
He was a running back for the Detroit lions.
Actually rookie of the year in 1967 his brother played football. Miller Afar.
Your uncle? My uncle,
her brother is Malvar junior and Michael far both played football.
My cousin Jerry Leviis, who they, and when we say played these guys,
everybody laid out in the NFL. Okay, I'm Jerry Ball A,
I can't even if I, I said I was gonna actually write them all down,
but it's something like 33 really family members have played in the NFL.
Oh my God. Coming from a sports family,
we had to play a sport so I can remember getting up in the mornings before
school, six, seven o'clock in the morning and having agility drills.
We lived on a house with Justin at home, in your back yard in the backyard.
We lived on a hill and I didn't have it as bad as my brothers because I played
tennis. I started playing tennis at three. Um,
but like in the winter time my dad would strap my brothers to the sled and my
dad was sitting in a sled and they would have to run up the hill with my dad in
the sled. Um, tire drills, everything. Do you have a sense of like,
why? I think for my dad,
sports opened up so many doors for him. My Dad's from Beaumont, Texas.
He was in Texas at a, you know, during segregation.
So sports allowed him to get out.
It allowed him to provide an excellent lifestyle for his family and being
drafted to the Detroit lions and being a football player in the Motown error.
Weekends at my house consisted of
Marvin Gay and Blim Barney and Charlie Sanders, who are all in the hall of fame.
Now my father actually an Lynn Barney sang background on Marvin Gaye's.
What's going on? No. Yes, they all,
my dad has a gold record. Oh man, that's crazy.
And when he stopped playing football,
he opened up his first car dealership and then another and another.
And for a time,
the mill far auto group was actually the largest African American owned business
in the country. I mean that's what football did for him.
Football gave my dad a life.
So Parker, if they had a toddler league he'd had been in it.
So you start looking for leagues like literally we moved to Georgia when Parker
was two and I found one that started at four and I'm like Ooh,
just two more years. It was like a countdown. Oh my gosh. One more year.
And when Parker turned four,
I mean I couldn't sleep the night before. I'm like yes, browse the day.
Parker has no idea what's going on. I go up there bright and early.
First person in line. Here's my check. Four years old,
full on contact football at four helmets, helmets, pads,
spring training. Wow. Parker had spring training.
Okay. He's going through the tires. He's four.
Okay. We don't even have team colors yet,
but I'm there in what I feel like the team colors should be in there and
Honolulu, blue and silver cause that's Detroit lives colors.
So this is just at the at spring training.
Then we get to the actual team practice. They immediately,
they named him the tank.
He was just plowing through people.
They were like tank top and coaches and the coaches at first practice.
I'm not thinking about the other parents in their little normal sized children
and the fact that by, you know, after the first day of practice,
three kids quit because Parker had just plowed them over. I'm like, yes,
my son is a beast
and then the season starts football in where we live is huge.
At four years old, they were tailgating. No,
I'm serious. The coaches had matching outfit. Then head gear like,
are you kidding me? You guys are talking on a microphones. And I'm like, wow,
this is, this is freaking serious.
And the coaches are cursing like you guys are playing like a bunch of em.
Like whoa, they're four. They only know what that is. Wow.
It's that serious.
Are you starting to think this is ridiculous at any point or it's just they were
like this? No. I'm like, this is ridiculous.
When he says she knew that that game of when parking steam would take the field
[inaudible] who go fight win didn't matter.
You know the proudest moment as a parent,
my son gets a personal file.
I know it's terrible.
I'm my son just tackles this guy in the coach,
you know, he would always do make the meat dirt. So after he tackled him,
my son took his head like eat dirt. I'm like,
I had to keep myself down cause the kid who was eating mom who,
sorry. So at that, that's what that evening is.
When I realize I'm like, Gosh,
if my son was just attacked by a 65 pound four year old,
I'd probably be a bit upset. So this is a progression. This is okay.
They've got the matching outfits. Okay,
the eat dirt and then you go home and you reflect on the day and I start to,
you know, I'm like, oh my gosh, what about this kid's mom?
But then we get to the super bowl. So I'm fanatic again. The soup,
the four or five year old Superbowl. Yes. Okay.
My son has a trophy that's it's probably three feet tall and crazy part is that
as all this is happening,
as Parker's taking the field with this four and five year old teammates,
a family member had really, really started showing signs
[inaudible]
signs of like a CTE, chronic traumatic encephalopathy,
which is the what comes from like concussion,
concussion after concussion symptoms include memory loss,
sometimes bouts of anger.
In this case it was depression was suicidal thoughts.
It was everything. Was it other family members saying, Hey,
have you noticed this or was it he himself saying I've,
I don't feel right. It was everybody else seen
it was getting phone calls like, Hey,
I need you to come get him because he's having dangerous thoughts.
Yeah.
And at that very time knowing that I went and signed my son up for football,
what's going on there? Cause that's what we do.
It's almost like a split personality.
Registering him for football was just as natural as getting up every morning and
brushing my teeth. Then you have the other half as a mother,
daughter,
niece of NFL athletes who sees what happens.
On the flip side and while Parker was playing the part of her that did see what
happens on the flip side,
that that part would campaign to raise awareness of CTE with other parents.
I was on a mission. I had met with people,
I was doing health fairs, helping create a, this pamphlet that would go out.
Meanwhile, since Parker was playing my dad now is affected really your dad too?
My Dad is now showing signs. Um, how old is he now?
My Dad just turned 70 and you know,
I'm seeing it now with his speech, with his thought pattern, you know,
running bags. What do you do man? You leave with the head. That was, you know,
but I can't stop myself from wanting my son to play football.
It's just the Cree. I can't, I can't even explain it. If he wanted to play,
I would be out there. He would be at practice. You know,
even who tosses the ball around with him in the yard,
hoping that he'll fall in love with football me and ask for Parker.
When I asked Parker how did he, like the season,
his favorite things were the trophy and the pizza party at the end.
He had no desire. You want to play again next season? No,
this past year or last year. Hey Parker, do you want to play this year? No,
I want to play soccer.
Would you bring up to like when would a next possible season be?
Well registration is in June.
Um,
and this would be what kind of, he's eight. Yeah,
I W W
I don't want him to, if he decides to play the game,
cool. If not
be grudgingly. But that's okay too.
I don't want to force him to play, especially this early.
So I stand firm on both sides of the debate.
I know that's what makes it ridiculous.
I stand firm that children should not play football.
I also stand firm that children should play football,
that it's a great sport and our current solution to this quandary,
he can be a kicker.
So now we're out there. We're,
I'm up this year we're dedicated to teaching them how to kick.
Maybe soccer's left such a bad, bad idea. Good practice for the Alamo.
All the kickers came from soccer. I'm like, what? What the what?
There is no black kickers. There was no black punters.
Even the kicker gets hit every so often now, every so often.
But there is a stiff penalty for that. Lose 15 years. Um,
how about this point in the conversation?
Parker came home from school.
I'm not exactly sure how an eight year old should look, but um,
he's a pretty big kid. Come sit with me.
Sit on your lap. So do you know why I can't even talk to you then?
Why you don't know what? Oh, about football? Yeah.
Uh, I've played,
I played for about six weeks I think.
Was that great? Something like that. Cause you just weren't really that into it?
No, I just still, um,
the only reason I don't want to play it anymore is because I made someone
swallow dirt and like that stuff is kind of messing up my history and I don't
want to get anyone else hurt. Messing up your history. Yeah.
It's just missing up history in my life. Does. I mean you could. Well,
I don't know what that means. What does that mean? That's messing up.
It's like messing up. It's making me have bad memories.
I want to have good memories. Um, and I can animate someone. Swallow dirt.
I feel guilty. It was an accident.
I just tackled him and man, it happened.
Did you feel bad about it right away or you just feel bad about now when you
think back on it? I feel bad about it every time I think back. Really? Yes.
I thought I heard somebody crying or something.
I thought I heard tears or I saw him.
So you didn't like doing that? Yeah.
Do you like watching football? I'm, no,
I'm not that in the football like the rest of my family. Why not?
I usually think about just having fun and not winning.
Where'd you get that? Is that from your mom? No,
I just know that winning is just for people trying to be better than everyone in
bullying. Women is from winters. No, like mom.
That's what I mean. It's trying to have fun, not just to be rude to people.
When you,
when all you're going to do is like take a trophy and say you're better than
them. It's not fair to the others. Do like other sports,
uh, or I really care about that either.
I really want to do synchronized swimming.
Really. Is that true? Is that true?
[inaudible] why? I'm mostly because when I, um, saw something about it,
it looked kind of cool. Like, um,
people are doing a lot of cool swimming tricks,
so I kind of thought it was something for me. Yeah. He's the,
this you play in me synchronized swimming where you're like,
you're like,
this guy's going to come talk to me about football and I'm going to tell him
that I want to do think or nice way. Right. No, you like it. Yeah. Uh,
yeah. It sounds good to note. He likes to swim. So you said swimming,
but I guess we don't have to worry about that. That would be a team sport. Yeah.
So, wow. This kind of exhausting. Yeah.
It's all right. We can stop. We can stop. Thanks to my name.
Parker Bartell for letting, uh,
letting store an invade their home and exhaust them on short notice. And by the,
when Monet went back
and counted all the relatives that had been in the NFL, it wasn't 33,
it was 13, but that's still, it's a lot. Any case,
here's the logical question that we felt like we should ask at least somewhere
in this show. Give and takes experience. You know,
we're football was practically his birthright but he is opting out.
Are there a lot of tanks out there?
Like is football the sport tanking nationally?
Generally we asked Molly Webster to find out finding when one of my friends,
we call him tank, but that's cause he can drink a lot
and my dad can't remember his name and just goes, how's tank?
How's that tank fellow still drinking a lot. In any case,
I started making some calls. The high school coaches, Hey, can you hear me?
Winning teams? Losing teams. Yep. Oh sweet.
And to kind of get a handle on the bigger picture, I called this guy
dry and Marcellus Wallison and I am a freelance sports reporter.
Um, I don't know. Would you want to name the places where I,
no, we'll keep it short.
Okay, so then, yeah, just the name and freelance sports rather.
Okay.
So in 2013 he was an intern at the Wall Street Journal's sports desk
and my first week a article was published on ESPN that suggested based on solely
pop Warner youth football numbers.
Hey, by the way, pop Warner is, is no longer the person pop Warner,
but he is a youth football league. Okay.
John Solely pop one and youth football numbers.
Youth football was declining pretty significantly.
Oh, do you remember what the, what the drop was? Yeah,
around 5% a year between 2010 and 2012
when people saw these numbers, they were like, oh my God, why exactly.
5% doesn't sound too bad. Well,
I mean if you assume that the 5% drop doesn't change,
that's what it drops by every year.
Then in 15 years you're in the neighborhood of like 50% less kids playing ball.
Wow.
If this is true, it's spells the end of football.
The idea is you, if you don't have the kids getting trained in like pop Warner,
then they're not going to middle school football.
They're not going to high school football and they're not going to college
football. So they're not going in the NFL. Right. Needless to say,
everyone was like, oh my God,
is this actually true or is there more to these numbers than meets the eye?
So Ryan starts digging into them. Yeah,
sorry, I couldn't find a context to put them in
and he doesn't look just at pop Warner numbers.
He looks at all of the youth football leagues.
And what I began to realize was that the drop wasn't as drastic,
but that there was indeed a drop.
But it's not as big as everyone was saying.
All right,
okay. Your relief will be short lived because,
because there's a bigger story.
When Ryan looked at participation across all youth sports, not just football,
I came back with noted drops in all of the biggest youth.
It's not just that football's, everything's decreasing.
So nothing was rising except for Lacrosse and for hockey.
So we had our headlines. Kids aren't playing sports, you know,
football gets all of the attention. Football gets all of the controversy.
You don't really hear about basketball or soccer or baseball.
So you don't have any reason to think that those sports aren't still as healthy
as they've always been. But then when you go and look,
you see a drop that is comparable to the drop in the sport that's got
everybody's hair on fire and you just wonder why this has been going on.
So silently
is this an extension of the whole concussion thing? Yes.
Concussions were definitely part of the conversation but so we're, you know,
budget issues and kids specializing in sports and getting burnt out.
So basically everyone had their reasons and every school has their reasons.
But the guys I talked to,
they just kept coming back to land on this point that had nothing to do with
safety.
Cause you know the bottom line, if today, if, if a kid doesn't like the score,
he just hits restart.
He just starts the game over it cause they can get on a video game,
they can play, they start losing, they hit reset,
hit the button and lay another game. They just hit a button and start over.
That's JT Curtis, j j Woodward and George Salus. They're in Louisiana,
California and Kansas.
And I heard this refrain not just from them but I heard this in Ohio.
I heard this in Michigan and by this point I was like Jesus, that's the problem.
It's funny cause it says if I'm,
all the coaches all across the nation are reading the same book or going to the
same bars.
Something because literally everyone I've talked to has brought this up.
Is it just that everyone's said it to each other so much that it's,
I keep telling you about United at all.
It's because we all deal with the problem.
So all these coaches I talked to were like, you can't go hit reset.
You can't hit reset. You can't hit reset. Like these kids are used to like,
it's, I've keep, I sound so old.
They're basically saying that what they find is they feel like there's some some
commitment issue now I will only play if I win. I only want to win. Yeah,
so the interesting thing was is the coaches I talked to at the powerhouse
schools were like, well,
we're not actually having trouble getting kids because we win,
but the other schools and their conference,
they know that coaches and athletic directors,
and then I talked to some schools that had four fitting teams that ended up
forfeiting games. They said like,
you just don't get the kids that will work their asses off and ride the bench
where everybody wants to eat.
It's just somehow it feels like they expect to win or it isn't worth the effort
or it's just that there are so many options.
Like why would you choose the losing option?
Tell you what. When I used to go home after school,
I turned the TV on and there's three channels. It's all I had.
They usually will show him
operas and so there was really no reason I w I had no reason to stay home.
[inaudible]
now you go home, there's 150 stations you can find something
you want to watch or you get out again. All right,
so whether you think it's video games or parenting or fear of concussions or
whatever reason you want to choose seems to be the largest thing that happens in
these conversations about sports like football is it,
it doesn't actually seem to be about football.
It's like some kind of negotiation between the generations because like back in
the 1870s the Harvard kids,
they were using football as a way to say back to the previous generation like
look how look how tough we are. Look how manly we are. Maybe this generation
is turning away from sports like football also to say something back to the
previous generation, something about the world they want to live in.
Sports do suggest things about society and about reality that we are slowly
trying to move removed from existence.
The idea that somehow physicality matters more than the mind and that people
really aren't equal and that if you yell at someone and challenge their manhood,
that's awful.
I mean overt masculinity of any kind.
It's not something that we're in the mood to celebrate these days.
So it could be if you believe writer Chuck Klosterman and it could be that some
kids are choosing away from sports like football because to play football things
that we want,
it means that on some level you have to support or at least entertain ideas that
you don't like, you know,
or at least so you don't want to admit that you like except he admits it.
I do think there's something unconscious about me that is drawn to the problems
in the game. They are based around what it really is, which is a
two dudes slamming it.
Yes. Because I, you know, I mean, okay, this is like I'm doing,
I guess I'm doing pop psychology on myself,
but what you are fully entitled to because it's fascinating. But I,
I sometimes wonder if, if
somehow part of me misses that from my life that you know,
that my life is built around sitting at a computer and avoiding conflict and
basically thinking about things and going on the radio and talking about what
they might mean, you know, and sort of like, what are they metaphors for?
What is this culture? What is it telling us, you know? And that, that,
that perhaps football allows me to sort of, even though I'm not playing it,
I'm just watching it. But somehow by watching it,
it allows me to tap into something that is no longer part of my life because my
mind has trained me not to want it.
My mind knows not to look for conflict, Eh,
now I do.
I suspect that I was socialized to believe that that would be a positive,
exciting thing. Absolutely. I mean, I, uh, you know,
I talked about sports with father more than we talked about every other thing we
ever talked about. I had a great relation with my dad. Uh, he passed away.
I loved him. We had a great relationship,
but we definitely spent more time discussing sports.
Then I would say every other thing that we discussed,
even though he would always say like the most important thing he'd like,
I'd come home from whatever, you know. And he would be like,
so how was school today? And now I'd tell him, oh, school was briefly.
And he would be like, uh, well, you know,
academics and the most important thing.
And then we would talk about football practice for an hour. Like you're like,
you know, it's like it would be, that would be,
so I realized that my relationship to football goes back to, you know, my,
I have two older brothers, man,
we spent so much time throwing the football around and, and,
and my brother,
one of both my brothers were very good football players and like one played at
the college level. And as a first grader I was so proud of that, you know,
I would tell Ya. So there's all of these things that are,
I'm sure are creating obstacles. For me, seeing this clearly,
and maybe the kind of person who sort of like this guy is crazy that he's not
seeing the obvious thing that he is actually saying that we need to somehow find
a moral justification for a game that's probably killing dudes for money.
I don't know. It's not my fault. That's how I feel. I can't get around you man.
I'm sorry.
Whoa. There you go.
You have two new messages. Message one. Hi,
this is Chuck Klosterman. This is Monet and Parker Bartelle. Hi,
this is Kat Curtis calling. Have a bit of a cold, so I'm ready to.
Lab is produced by Jen Abba, Matt. Ever Mirage.
Our staff includes Alan Horn, Soren wheeler, Howard [inaudible],
Molly Webster, Melissa Donald's feelings. Jamie Yorklyn,
Livy Lynn, Libby, Andy Mills, Kelsey Padgett.
In that IPI was how from Iron Lat gold winner,
the mind neo, Damion machete, Nasser Philly prime,
and Denny Lewis.
Radiolab involves many staff members with names that are hard to pronounce.
That's the thanks to Richard Chick from Benji. Robert Wheeler, definitely.
But some. Debra creditee. Fred War Decker, Joel Flood,
Eric Anderson in the Cumberland County historical society by and this message.
Okay, I'm back. One last thing. One last thing. Okay.
If you grew up on inside the NFL as I did,
this is for you some voice using the Chicago players crowded along the sideline
as a shield. Excellent.
Diane circled the bench and started running again
behind the line of scrimmage. How's your
launch the ball 40 yards down.
Field x and dine darted back onto the field. All the alone.
You're the Chicago goal for a moment.
It was a frozen scene in a stage drama.
The bowl hung in the year a tantalizing possibility,
good x and Diane Richard, would he catch it or drop it?
Defender's wheeled and stared downfield spectators watching from the stands
found that the breath had died in their collective throats.
The spiraling balls seem to defy physics. What made it stay up?
When would it come down in that long moment,
which 27,000 spectators mashed together on benches and crammed on platforms may
have felt their loyalty to the home team evaporate in the grip of a powerful new
emotion. They may have noticed something they never had before,
that Obole traveling through space traces a profoundly elegant path.
They may have realized something else that it was beautiful.
The ball struck it's human target x and died,
caught the pass all alone and trotted over the Chicago Gold Mine.
The stadium exploded in sound and motion. I'm a Chicago sideline.
Coaches and players screen without roads on the field.
The referee signaled the score, but in the stands,
the spectators marveled.
The crowd hilditch ref in amazement for a time and stifled this local pride and
turned loose its enthusiasm. And she ran for the Indians,
the Chicago Daily Tribune reporter. He was the game breaker.
The rest was just anticlimax.
The final score was 18 to four for Carlyle.
The long past had arrived in Chicago,
although by a circuitous and out of bounds route,
the Indians declared the Tribune had given such an exhibition of its
possibilities as will not soon be forgotten in that vast wrong.
That was Mr. Scott Graham Voice of inside the NFL. Thank you, Scott.
You are the awesome miss voice ever. And uh,
that was original music by Dylan Keefe. Bye.